كنت على بعد شبر ونصف تقريبًا من
معرفة بوتين عندما التقطت تلك
الصور ويمكنني أن أشعر أن تنفسه على
يدي ، لذا فالأمر حميمي بقدر ما يمكن أن
يحصل على اسمي بلوح ، فأنا راوي قصص
أعرف أنني مصور ولكن  حقًا
أنا راوية قصص ، لقد كان الوقت هو أفضل شخص
في العام وتم إرسالي إلى موسكو
لالتقاط الصورة فور وصولك ترى
هذا الجدار العملاق عالي الأمان مغطى
بالقناصة ثم تحت تهديد السلاح ، تم قيادتي
إلى المبنى ثم بوتين
يدخل وهو محاط
بمترجميه وفريقه من مستشاريه وعشرة
حراسه الشخصيين ، إنه أمر مخيف للغاية
وقلت له إنني من أشد
المعجبين بالبيتلز ، هل تحدث معي ويقول إنني
أحب البيتلز ، لذلك قلت ما هو
البيتلز المفضل لديك  وقال بول
فقلت ما هي أغنيتك المفضلة
وقال: آه بالأمس فكر في الأمر ،
فهمت أن هذا الاتصال هو الذي
سمح لي بالاقتراب لأنه
أدرك فجأة أنني لست خائفًا منه ، فأنا
لا أخاف من قبضتي.  أنا هناك
للقيام بورص نزيه  سمة الشخص هذه هي
الطريقة التي حصلت بها على الحقيقة والحقيقة هي
أن هذا هو وجه القوة ، إنه
وجه السلطة الباردة والمفارقة هي
بقدر ما أظهرته مثل هذا
الزعيم القومي القاسي المعارض
لبوتين.  لقد
زعموا بأنفسهم أن يظهروا
كل ما هو خطأ في Power
أصبح شعار المعارضة
كما ادعت حركة حقوق المثليين ذلك
أيضًا عندما ادعى الناس
صورة وهي مرتبطة بطريقة ما بالزمن
الذي نعيش فيه.  هذا هو
أعظم شرف يمكن أن نتمناه لما
أسعى لتحقيقه هو إضفاء الطابع الإنساني على
نظام الطاقة لطرح سؤال مهم جدًا
من أنت من أنت حقًا